let's talk about amateur what you shot
it on how you secure the locations yes
so amateur you know is the short prequel
for manchild and and I came about
because I felt that making it short was
the last box I could check as far as you
know okay I'm gonna write the script is
a script good does it get recognition
from you know places like IFP and lay
considered as a good a grant from
Tribeca okay those boxes are checked
it's been externally validated okay
what's next
well can I run a crowdfunding campaign
that's big enough that shows people hey
there's interest in this movie and then
I have an audience that would end up you
know result in me bringing you know six
figures of financing to the table with
myself in addition to the script okay
that box is checked what else can I do
okay let's see if I can make a short
that's a proof of concept that's the
same genre that shows I can't direct
basketball and I understand the sport
that shows I can direct young
african-american actors because the
entire movie you know they keep the star
of the movie is in every single scene
it's not going to be a movie where there
was a bunch of adults talking and that's
the majority of the film so the short
came about because I wanted to do
something that was of the same genre and
actually has some of the same characters
as the feature as a proof of concept and
when I initially had the idea for it
it was starting out very small I was I
was thinking about shooting it myself
and most of it was gonna take place and
you know school hallways which I figured
would be easier to secure than an actual
gymnasium and at the time I was meeting
with my producer chip horahan who
produced frozen river and any day now
and we were talking about the feature
and I sent him over the the short script
and he liked it a lot in Austin you know
now the team is to Austin were I'm
scouting gyms in New York City he's
scouting gyms in New Jersey it's coming
together
I went
with my DP Greg Wilson who he and I
again had had a number of conversations
about the feature he read the script and
I sent him the script for the short and
said hey I'm trying to make this you
know soon really soon and then our team
was three so Austin we had multiple
people calling in favors and it was
becoming larger than what I originally
imagined but in a good way because I
wrote it to be something that was very
achievable knowing all the challenges
that the feature is facing I essentially
started with what can I write that is
basically a conversation between two
people in one location and can I make it
dramatic and can I make it rewarding and
all of that is gonna be dependent on you
know the writing and the directing and
the performances in the story all of
which are the most important things in
filmmaking so there was that sort of
challenge that I set out for myself
thankfully chip and Greg were also you
know pushing the ball up the hill and we
were able to call in just a lot of
favors because one of the one of the
great things about doing a weekend shoot
is someone you know might be available
that weekend they're not working
otherwise so you can go get equipment or
personnel for less than it would have
been you know that's one of the
challenges when you're shooting a movie
for 20 or 30 days you can't call on a
favorite for 20 or 30 days so you know
originally we were gonna shoot on my red
scarlet and Greg my DP hadn't shot on
red before so it was a good opportunity
for him I mean not that he hasn't shot
of things that high-end I mean he should
be gonna Lex's and things but but
getting the right experience was gonna
be good either way but then when the
weekend rolled around because we've been
already talking to rental houses through
all of our connections other equipment
became available through friends from
the rental house we didn't know what
lenses we would be shooting on until the
day before when they said hey we have
these areas uma vailable and we said
okay great we're shooting on that now so
we ended up not even touching my red
scarlet because Greg's friend
Ranson epic that was available so also
we were shooting on that and I think for
an online release you probably can't
tell the difference between 4k and 5k
and but of course it was just well we
have a better camera we'll use that it's
not costing us anything like it
literally would have been more expensive
for us to go buy a t4i DSLR and bring
its asset and shoot on that because we
were able to get you know equipment
based on a favor so you know the idea
was that I didn't want to make excuses
for this short other than the challenges
of the locations and the fact that it's
you know not necessarily an
action-packed like viral online video
with music and special effects and
everything I mean I think there are
challenges of releasing online in that
sense but I didn't want to have to make
excuses for the production quality the
sound quality you know the gym like
these are all things that are as a trio
we were able to secure into scout and
you know once you have a good DP you
know Greg has connections to crew
members and you know we pay people but
we would not we didn't pay people but
you know they would have been paid if
this was a mayonnaise commercial so we
were able to bring it in and you know I
think the production quality is really
high you know we had one sound guy not
to and he was able to do the booming and
the mixing and everything himself and so
really we were able to pull it together
and I'm really proud of it and so
hopefully you know that proof of concept
is gonna be checking that last box that
I that I spoke of and saying oh okay now
I get the vision for the feature and now
I get the level of you know performance
and storytelling that that you know
makes you want to see the feature and
you know we'll see what what comes
henceforth from releasing this so you
had 48 hours was that right to do the
entire film or just use the gym oh we
didn't have 48 hours to use the gym we
actually we wrapped the gym in a single
day and the challenge was so chip my
producer found this great locations
Edison New Jersey and we went and we
scouted it and we said this is great the
challenge was that a kids soccer game
had the gym reserved in the middle of
the day so you know it was a weekend
shoot a day and then a night you can't
really do a night and a day because the
crew is gonna you know there's be no
turnaround time so we had to shoot the
gym on Saturday and the exterior night
on Sunday so we couldn't you know avoid
this kids soccer game so yeah we had one
day in the gym and in the middle we had
to move all our equipment the kids come
in and play their soccer game and then
continue shooting which meant that we
ended up shooting a number of things out
of order which meant that you know we
had last time in the gym but we were
able to schedule our lunch when they
were in in the gym and then go shoot our
locker room scene and then come back but
literally we were picking up you know
there's a couple edits where someone's
having a conversation and it's a
two-shot and then the close up they are
cutting to was you know four hours later
after these kids have played a soccer
game and we're trying to match our
lighting and there are a lot of
logistical challenges to the short that
I that I hope don't show up when you
watch it especially given the fact that
you know there's the short opens with
some action and that always takes time
to film to get it right and had to
actually match and and you know to
single camera shoot so we're recovering
things from multiple angles so most of
that short of that nine minutes short
75% of that is shot after launch on day
1 in the gym so you know it's not a
luxurious situation to be saying oh you
know okay take 16 we're going no it's
very few takes it is moving very quickly
it's everyone sort of you know making
sacrifices as far as what you can do
with lighting how many tapes you can get
you know even just changing this staging
because the lights are a certain way you
can get to the scene faster if you don't
you know move over there so I think it
you know it was a really good set of
challenges to face to be able to prove
myself in that environment and you
I'm proud of what we ended up with
regardless of all of those challenges
but especially because you know when you
know what you went through as a
filmmaker the audience is never gonna
know that so you sort of just have to be
internally proud about what you were
able to achieve given the limited
circumstances you had how many people
then were on the crew was it five you
know we had we had a sizable crew it was
definitely the largest group I'd ever
worked with because the crew was greater
than myself you know I'm used to our web
series that we did exactly from in my co
director he and I were the crew so we
were the sound you know camera
everything this was actually the first
time that I'd stepped onto a set and my
name was on the slate and Oh action oh
this is great you know I'm not I'm not
pulling focus I can actually give the
actor a note and not you know be
distracted by the fact that I blew a
focus pull myself at the same time so
you know I think we had they were about
12 people on set including including you
know cast so but you know we were able
to get a lot out of our crew you know
and someone that was some of that was
you know people who came on last-minute
for free and but yeah that was
definitely it was good to be able to
have access to the lighting setup that
we had and be able to have you know a
great di T Tom Wong on set there's been
a lot of red stuff and just you know
working with professionals is you know
there's no substitute for it so it was
great to you know be able to get as much
as we did in a short amount of time
because everybody was proficient at
their job and everyone was on the same
page
you